there is a Christian pastor warning of a Jew
coup to remove Donald Trump, and I must tell
you, I'm surprised it took this long to become
a storyline and I'll explain that in a second.
So I know that very often when we talk about
antisemitism on the show, we end up kind of
taking heat from the left and the right, the
right will often just respond to stories about
antisemitism with antisemitism often directed
at me proving my point. Sadly, there are some
on the left who when I talk about antisemitism,
we'll minimize it. They'll say, you know,
Jews aren't really discriminated against.
Sometimes they even fall into the same thinly
veiled antisemitic tropes that exist across
the political spectrum, but I have to talk
about it because this is a real problem that
we have on our hands. Europe is increasingly
riddled with antisemitism. Horrible situation
recently on a London subway. You can look
that up if you're curious. Lots of stories
to tell. Not for today though. Trump, even
though his daughter Ivanka converted to Judaism
and his son-in-law, Jared Cushner is Jewish,
Trump has still hugely coalesced and catalyzed
white nationalism and antisemitism.
They've said it to me. I've spoken to people
like Richard Spencer who explain it to me.
The latest report from the anti defamation
league about antisemitism is horrible. We
even saw Republicans on the house intelligence
committee, including their, uh, lead counsel,
Steve caster play off of the antisemitic trope
of dual loyalty to try to discredit impeachment
witness. Lieutenant Colonel Alexander Veneman,
his family are Jewish immigrants from Europe.
And during the impeachment inquiry hearings
in November, Republicans tried to play up
this antisemitic trope of dual loyalty. And
it was quite frankly inevitable that eventually
there would be a faction that turns the entire
movement to hold Trump accountable for the
things he has done into an antisemitic trope
or conspiracy theory. And now we are seeing
the idea of that movement, uh, the entire
movement to get rid of Trump, to hold him
accountable to impeach him. It is now being
chalked up as a Jewish conspiracy by more
and more people.
And again, I'm shocked it took this long because
when you step back from it, there are just
too many overlaps between the ways that the
right has defended Trump and common antisemitic
tropes. The deep state cabal of people working
to control the public facing instruments of
power like the presidency. They think that's
what impeachment is. And they often say that
that's what Jews do. There's a lot of overlap
there. There are too many Jews involved in
the impeachment hearings. Adam Schiff is Jewish.
That democratic counsel, Daniel Goldman is
Jewish. It's the Jews. Once again. So it was
obvious that it was only a matter of time
until this happened. And now our old buddy,
I'm not being serious about that. Christian
pastor Rick Wiles, a truly sick individual
is saying that impeachment is an attempted
Jew. [inaudible] I can't possibly say it like
he says it. So take a listen.
That's the way the Jews work there they are
deceivers they plot, they lie, they do whatever
they have to do to accomplish their political
agenda. This impeach Trump movement is a Jew
CU and the American people better wake up
to it really fast because this thing is moving
now towards a vote in the house and then a
trial in the Senate. We get to have a trial
by before Christmas. This country could be
in civil war, a Christmas time. That's right.
Uh, Juku. There it is. And you know the thing
is there has been whacked out antisemitic
Christian pastors for a long time. That's
not news worthy in and of itself. What's different
today is that they are more emboldened than
ever by Donald Trump and not only is there
a risk of real world violence, they are pushing
it. Here's Rick Wiles. Moments later starting
to talk about, you know the military members
of the military are going to have to pick
a side here either with the Juku or against
the Juku.
Members of the U S military are going to have
to take a stand just like they did in the
1860s with the civil war. They're going to
have to decide are you fighting for the North
or the South members of the government are
going to have to take a side instead of North.
South is going to be left or right. People
are going to be forced possibly by this Christmas
to take a stand.
Okay.
Because of this Jew coup in the United States,
we have weeks to stop it. That's why I'm speaking
out. That's why I'm putting everything on
the line. Say this is a coup led by Jews to
overthrow the constitutional he elected president
of the United States. And it's beyond removing
Donald Trump. It's removing you and me.
Wow. Really courageous. A wacky evangelical
Christian pastor blames the Jews for something
we've never seen that before. Really. I admire
his courage and taking a stand on that. So
we're seeing a very disturbing combination
here of right-wing nationalism, antisemitism,
and Christian nationalism. And what's worst
about all of this is that we want to be careful
not to participate in the escalation of violence.
We don't want any violence. We want Trump
removed by people voting them out. Or if a
constitutionally, uh, enshrined impeachment
process removes Trump, then okay, we don't
want violence. They are both the people saying
there might be violence and the people who
would do it. And the people who are starting
to allude to physical violence to resist any
kind of outcome that leads to Donald Trump
being out of the white house. So we then ended
up in a position where I find it necessary
to remember we shouldn't be violent like them.
We can't be violent like them. They do. By
the way, though, these evangelical, I hate
to even call them churches, so-called church
churches, they need to lose their tax exempt
status. This is political advocacy, which
violates the tenants of uh, those non non
profit statuses that are given to these evangelical
groups in churches. They need to stop spreading
racism. They need to stop spreading nationalism
and antisemitism. But by predicting violence,
they are also likely to cause violence because
fundamentally it's what they want. It's a
sick reality that we're dealing with right
now. But again, I'm surprised it took this
long for the antisemitism to overlap with
the movement to hold Trump accountable. It's
happening now. We are seeing it. We will have
more coverage of this on the show's Instagram
page. Make sure you're okay.
Following us there at David Pakman show. And
while you're there, follow me on Instagram
as well at David
dot [inaudible] the David Pakman
show@davidpakman.com.